Tony Dungy the hall-of-famer working of
course for NBC football night in America
joining us hey Tony how are you I'm
doing well then and it's good to hear
your voice and here you kind of debating
that run game yeah alright if I said you
could bring back only one player if
you're Tennessee you can have Derrick
Henry or Ryan Tannehill for the short
run I'm bringing back Derrick Henry
because I think everything revolves
around him but I do agree with you it
could go you know those big backs that
that have that kind of Buy and that kind
of style you know we just haven't seen
them last seven eight nine years like
that do you think the Packers
overachieve Tony that maybe they weren't
a great team I think they really did
when you look at the regular season and
we saw some games where they struggled
and you know they played well and they
won games they've won some close games
I think I saw us that they had the least
amount of net points for a 13 game
wonder ever they won a lot of close
games and I think that is a sign of good
coaching and they did as much as they
could with their their talent level I
was anything surprising to you in these
two games just the fact that Kansas City
could make so many state mistakes and
fall behind early and not panic in those
big games it's hard to fall behind like
that maybe two weeks in a row I think
Chris Jones may be there Bob Sanders I
mean when he came in the lineup and did
some things yesterday it made a big
difference but they better not make
those kind of early mistakes and fall in
that hole against San Francisco yeah I
was wondering about that that you know
you fall behind it the Texans in the
Titans that's different than falling
behind against San Francisco because San
Francisco has maybe the best defense and
that running attack no matter who's
running the ball it feels like they're
gonna be able to dominate time of
possession yep to up the clock and then
you're not going to score on every
possession
Kansas City is going to score on San
Francisco
this isn't a defense that you're gonna
go out and score seven straight
touchdowns again do we know who Jimmy
Garoppolo is I think he's a good player
and he really benefits from that system
and he is playing and giving them what
they need there's been some games where
he's had to come through down in New
Orleans he had to put up points and he
pit he hasn't had to do that that often
and he's had some games like this where
he's relied on the defense in the run
game but I think they have confidence in
him and I think when they need him to
he'll deliver well the fact that the
onliest of throw eight passes and you
blow out Aaron Rodgers in the Packers I
mean that's you know we talk about
systems and you know San Francisco got a
system running attack here they do and I
played against that when Mike Shanahan
was was coaching and we played some
games against Denver where they beat us
just like that and it got the lead early
and they ran and you couldn't get him
off and you start run blitzing and doing
things and then you hit a couple
play-action passes and he's done it with
a lot of different types of quarterbacks
and a lot of different backs but the
same way that a script can flip if you
get behind and just like Tennessee
Derrick Henry was a non-factor in the
second half because the game was a
little different so it's a very good
system they can run it on anybody it's a
system that doesn't rely on a Derrick
Henry tight back they float three or
four different backs in there they -
they think it won't cut one thing that's
really probably not spoken of enough
Bobby Turner has been yes and had family
for a long time and you think of Terrell
Davis and unknown and Landis Gary and
Tatum fell and now Raheem most
Bobby Turner I don't know what he does
and I know he teaches these guys you get
one cut and that's it okay in the ball
but everybody comes in that system and
produces I'll leave you with this who
gets back to the Super Bowl first the
Titans of the Packers
the Titans Bay Packers playing the tough
division the Titans it's hard to win
that way every year now maybe Ryan
Tannehill it's more confidence and maybe
he does become Jimmy Garoppolo and their
defense will continue to get better and
I tell you people don't know how to deal
with these running games now Tennessee
and San Francisco do things that people
aren't ready for because everybody's
looking at how do we stop these passing
attacks from stop Patrick my home it's
hard to just get bludgeoned and there's
nothing you can do to stop it
so that's a good question I think I'm
going to say Green Bay in the short run
but I think building a good foundation
two weeks off well you're not really off
when you after the title game and then
you get ready for the Super Bowl can you
over prepare for the Super Bowl you know
I had some good mentors and we always
tried to really prepare that first week
when you're at home and you've got a
kind of standard procedure hey let's put
the game plan in and then don't it just
it too much that second week use that
week in Miami just to relax kind of get
in the floor things don't over evaluate
that second week so that's how I always
tried to do it and coach Noll did it
that way and the people that I've been
around but yeah 14 days is a long time
I'd you know what I overthought kicking
the devil we track this all week and at
home pops the ball to the corners
popping it up and then I got down there
with that extra week and thought oh we
can't be scared we got to go right at
him and bad idea we should have played
that first Monday I want the kick to it
what did you say on the sidelines as you
watch has to return that opening kick
for attention honey I told our team the
night before the last meeting we had the
chapel service medicine no there's
always going to be a storm especially
that year we're having all of these up
and down so I said we're going to get a
storm
we'll just gotta be ready whenever it
happens fight roots stay together and so
I like to kick off he runs it back in 12
seconds were down 7 nothing everybody's
looking at me and I said I talked to the
storm was coming over first place we're
back your coach make me look good here
what is the curfew how serious is curfew
during Super Bowl week you know what I
did then I told we went down on Monday
and I said we're not going through
anything we've got the the press deal on
to the Wednesday is when we'll kick
things off Edgerrin James had just see
it going Arizona but he's lived in Miami
I said heads you got these guys just
don't let anybody go to jail I don't
care what I don't want to know what you
do the first two days and then Wednesday
morning we're going to take down and but
you guys do what you need to do and have
fun experience it for a day and a half
and that's what we did then we got on
our normal routine but I think you can
you can be too tight and you can stay
there and not let them have any fun and
enjoy the tourney and it doesn't work
out always great to talk to you tone oh
it's good
Thank You bud alrighty I'll be in touch
have a good week and I'll make I'll see
you at the Super Bowl alrighty let's
Tony Dungy Hall of Famer joining us for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]